Joe Biden and his administration says a
surprise surprise they think that scotus
got it wrong after striking down student
loan forgiveness of course he does I
mean it's ridiculous if you want to sit
here and make the argument that student
loan forgiveness is a good program I'll
disagree with you for some reasons I've
laid out last night in which I'll
summarize again in a moment here but
ultimately the idea that it is in
infringement of people's rights that the
Supreme Court is failing to stick to
constitutional ideals by not allowing
Joe Biden to redistribute wealth from
people who didn't receive higher
education or who paid off their loans to
people who did receive higher education
and or didn't pay off their loans or I
should say and didn't pay off their owns
not and or
is totally insane so I rattled off some
statistics last night people who
graduate with a PhD earn something like
000 a year as their median income and
their unemployment rate is about 1.1
percent people with uh Masters will earn
a median income about 78 000 their their
uh unemployment rate is slightly higher
but nothing too terrible than when you
go down to people who only have a high
school education their median income is
about 38 000 a year and they have a four
point something percent uh unemployment
rate so the idea that people who haven't
received higher education who are making
significantly less money and have a
higher unemployment rate should have
their wealth redistributed in order to
pay for people who did receive a higher
education and who are now in the
workforce with a higher earning
potential despite taking anywhere
between four and eight years out of the
workforce in order to attain that degree
and in many cases paid for some of their
living expenses rather than just their
education with those loans uh I think
it's just totally insane it's totally
unfair aside from being unconstitutional
I gotta argue that that should be the
status I gotta ask because I talked to
my mother about this couple days ago I
was like I'm not comfortable she's like
oh yeah they're starting to stop him
from but Ian you need and I'm like I'm
not comfortable getting other people to
tax money to pay off my debt and she's
like no it's only the billionaires taxes
that are you getting used not true so
this is the media I mean she watches
MSNBC yeah I guess they're just kind of
subtly not telling you the guys that
make 16 bucks an hour at McDonald's are
going to have to pay your taxes to for
me to get my student loans paid I mean
I'm fortunately I'm not in that bracket
now it's all well so what happened is I
got an email from the Department he's
not Biden he's not even doing it with
his mouth he's doing with the Department
of Education I got an email from them
that said we don't we think the Supreme
Court got it wrong this is like four
days ago or something so we're gonna do
it anyway but we're gonna do it with
people that are making up to 65 000 a
year or something like that and uh if
you if you don't want it opt out but
otherwise we're just gonna do it well I
think part of this for Biden is it's
it's a liver it's a it's a make or break
issue for him because he campaigned so
hard on I will get your student loans
forgiven right and so now we're getting
desperate we're getting closer to
election season and he needs to make
progress on this issue otherwise a lot
of his young voter base is going to say
but you said you'd pay off my debt and
you didn't I mean I have never
understood how Joe Biden is a viable
candidate for Democrats anyways but it's
important to note how big of an issue
this was this was a deciding factor for
young voters understandably so because I
don't I don't disagree with Sheamus on
the other hand the reality is if you
have tons of student loan debt because
you were told hey go take out a loan pay
for your education and it'll all work
out and you are feeling the consequence
of that I would also be looking for a
way to get out of this right I would
also be looking for help and Joe Biden
is failing on that front yeah not that
he shouldn't but you can see where it
becomes one one underlying theme of all
of our conversations tonight has been
the fostering of dependency by being
Godless materially contingent and now
the reason they're pushing for this and
I think I think we've got a model over
in the UK is because universe closed
captioning not available
in the UK to go to university then the
Cameron years pushed it up so they made
you stay in higher education until 18 so
they could fudge the unemployment
numbers and also because student loans
are a lot less and the taxpayer
guaranteed so they've just jumped them
up significantly I think they've doubled
them but I paid about 9 000 pounds a
year plus a maintenance loan that's
means adjusted so about four thousand
pounds so I've left about 40 000 pounds
in debt in total and we pay that back
over the course of about 30 years so we
wouldn't pay back until about 50. and
what they want to do is get you into the
institution which engenders a certain
kind of managerial monitor it's a
self-propagating managerial class like
like James Burnham would have talked
about and then you're in you're sort of
imbibed in sectionality and you become
the perfect kind of compliant corporate
drone who says whatever they can to get
ahead and what Brian wants here is to
create a dependent class both they want
to vote him in so they can alleviate the
debt and if you have a lot of debt and
of course you want a big government to
come and manage the economy to get rid
of it and also self-propagate more
people going to University so they're
not as scared about racking up all this
debt so then they're more compliant with
zdix in the future it's it's a it's a
genius self-propagation strategy yeah
um no wonder the Democrats want to push
it I think it is also interesting this
idea of getting people massively in debt
to the point where they don't have the
kind of economic leverage that they
ordinarily would without also giving
them some kind of property to show for
it I mean this is absolutely massive
this is one of the reasons I'm somewhat
sympathetic to the people who say they
want student loans to be forgiven
there's actually a few reasons
ultimately I don't agree with it for the
reasons I laid out earlier you make way
more money with the degree people are
making less money shouldn't have to pay
your degree off you still generally end
up making way more over the course of
your life than the degree ends up
costing uh but that said I I believe in
property ownership I believe that one of
the best economic strategies is to
create the conditions for the largest
amount of people to have property as is
possible so that everyone has a stake in
the system everyone does actually have a
a material stake in the future as well I
think when you're a nation of renters it
becomes a lot more difficult to get
people to care about a neighborhood or a
region and this is also part of why it's
so Insidious that organizations like
BlackRock and a lot of these investor
buyers have been swooping in and getting
all of the real estate in this country
and driving prices up for residential
owners and so I'm I'm sympathetic to the
argument even though I don't agree with
student loan forgiveness that we have
effectively created a class of people
who have the worst of Both Worlds
they're heavily in debt so they lack
leverage but they also don't along with
that debt have the leverage that comes
along with property ownership it's even
worse in the UK so in 1997 before Tony
Blair did education and immigration
reforms house prices were three times
median income now it's 11. oh my
goodness yep we only build 200 000 homes
a year we have net intake a 1.1 million
immigrants plus the people they're
battery farming in these hotels
migration watch UK has estimated that
because and this is the office for
National statistics that have found that
um migration is the leading cause of
population increase in the UK because
we've got a sub-replacement birth rate
as to most places most Western countries
yes and and higher education is the
cause of that I spoke to Stephen Shaw a
documentary filmmaker and he said that
this is one of the main reasons why
people are delaying having kids is
because they're spending up until their
mid-20s their Peak fertility is in
universities but um migration watch
found that by 2046 the rated population
increase that the UK is experiencing
will have to have 15 to 18 new cities
the size of Birmingham to accommodate
that we can't build it and and the
reason they're not building it this is
the final point is that 25 of of the
conservative parties donors are property
developers so they have the perverse
incentive to both keep prices high
enough that they're making a return on
investment but then keep a steady stream
of of inflated demand so they keep
building these terrible new houses that
are unfit for living and are basically
just knocked up new builds where the
like garden fences are like that so it's
the worst of Both Worlds in my country
yeah um I'd also like to mention one
more thing which is that Biden student
loan repayment uh changes could cost
around 475 billion dollars we've been
talking a lot about the negative
economic impact in an abstract though
valid way however these are the material
figures 475 billion dollars that's
that's the federal just print that in an
afternoon it's fine guys consequences at
all it never has right when is printing
way too much money ever gone badly for a
country
oh yeah I mean they just act like money
doesn't mean anything these numbers are
ridiculous and I think that's partially
because
um in my opinion the Democrat Party
relies on fixing things in the immediate
short term to maintain power and they
just kick the problems down the line in
fact they're more likely to blame
someone else right right
um I I think it's uh
I think it's a broken system and I am
sad for the people who have to deal with
the consequences but I don't think that
student loan uh debt forgiveness is is
the answer the way that it's being
proposed uh and and part of that for me
is it all goes back to a huge cultural
shift I mean you might be able to speak
this more than I can but uh our our
education system demands that you make
it through 12th grade and then we go to
12th grade you're supposed to leave and
go to college you're supposed to go four
degree and increasingly they say Well if
you really want to make more money you
should get a master's grade so it's an
additional two uh one to two years right
and well let's not forget about the
medical professions and going to law
school uh so you're in school forever
creating intense debt and also being
reliant on a system I think that the
American education system needs a
complete overhaul that encourages
independent thought because it should
incurate and current it should encourage
uh self-dependence and self-reliance I
think that is is ultimately what I don't
like and it's why it's important you
have these conversations about well if
you don't go to college what are your
options and in America we desperately
need people to go into to the trade
which you can have in a successful
living without taking on debt and in
some ways have a more free life right if
you are Shackled to student debt you
have to be conscious of that in in how
you financially plan for your life even
though you have this high paying degree
uh whereas if you are able to start
making significant amounts of money at a
young age imagine all the things that
you could do and the Investments you
make and the changes that you could have
yeah if you want to work on the uh if
you want to be an electrician you can
also be a YouTuber you can be an artist
and a Craftsman now in this world and
you can make a lot of money and you
don't need to go to school for it you
can learn the trade online that's the
overhaul I think we need is people need
to take it seriously the data is there
it is available on the internet well you
shot yourself to animated the age 12 or
something yeah I started when I was 12.
yeah and you're like now you're like a
quadrillionaire so YouTube locks you out
of your account of course yeah no yes
so uh we're still not waiting there were
um for people who don't know story short
yeah so I uh have a large YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we have 700
877 000 subscribers I make animated
cartoons there what happened was I have
a podcast on Rumble called shamer there
was another YouTube channel that was
pirating all of our content and
uploading it without our permission
permission we've been trying to flag
them to get them taken down because we
have our own shamer channel on YouTube
that we are posting Clips to and it's
been overshadowed in the algorithm by
this imposter
and so myself and many people were kind
of flagging to try to get it you know to
to bring it to YouTube's attention
nothing happened and uh so I just
flagged some of their their content and
then YouTube did take some of it down
and uh because I was able to prove that
this is content that was mine originally
that came from my Rumble Channel and
then we flagged some more of it and what
happened was and by we I mean me I was
just sat at my computer and flagged a
couple more videos uh and just showed
that they were uploaded without my
permission where they came from
originally they were the exact same
videos exact same titles exact same
lengths not mirrored or anything like
that uh and YouTube said that the claims
were fraudulent and that it was removing
all of the channels associated with the
Channel that I made the claim from so I
got an email for every YouTube channel
that I run from that email address that
had been taken down and it didn't
mention Freedom tunes and freedom Tunes
is still up but all related channels are
deleted and I cannot log into Freedom
Tunes every single single time I try to
there's no interface for me to do
anything it just takes me back to my
other Google accounts so I I've reached
out to the people at Google to see if we
can get this fixed I've reached out to
the people at YouTube I tweeted about it
a little bit earlier today let's uh hope
and pray that we're able to get this
sorted out thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time